we are kicking off hispanic heritage
month this morning celebrating the
diverse cultures from all over latin
america that are right here in the
valley this morning we're profiling the
award-winning mariachi program at the
college of southern nevada hector mejia
joining us live from the campus in north
las vegas with this beautiful
celebration we have really just been
enjoying good morning hector
good morning heather the students woke
up extra early to join us this morning
and to show us a little bit about what
mariachi platta is all about the program
been here around for uh this group
actually formed just a few years ago and
joining us live we have robert benora
fine arts department chair to talk to us
about the celebration that kicks off
here on campus tonight good morning sir
thank you
yes tonight is the kickoff for hispanic
heritage month
we will be doing an event from five to
seven at the tyrone thompson student
center here at the north las vegas
campus
and it's going to feature performances
by mariachi plata um it's our and first
exposure for
ballet folklorico at csn this is the
first semester that we've offered this
class you were telling me brand new
program brand new program it's three
weeks old so uh we've got community
groups we've got a bunch of community
resources we're trying to emphasize also
uh vaccinations on campus we have a
vaccination clinic for families
we have tequiro so there will be free
tacos free tacos everyone free taco
can't say no to free tacos and not say
no to free tacos tell us about the group
the group has been in existence
like this for about three years and
already winning top national honors
absolutely we're nationally recognized
already and we hope to be going back to
san antonio in december to mariachi
vargas extravaganza
and we hope to bring back
more more awards for csn that's uh
that's the goal right now
as chair of fine arts have you seen the
uh the program help students navigate
through school well it's just it's
getting the students inside the door
that's that's the important thing is is
we're trying to make sure that
uh especially the hispanic community is
is welcomed in and we're trying to make
sure that everything is that we're doing
culturally we're doing everything right
that we should be doing and this is just
another way to try to recruit for the
students to come in the door
and learn about and play some beautiful
music as well along the way absolutely
play mariachi and who knows they might
discover that you know
maybe i want to do this for a living or
do we offer over 200 degrees there's a
lot of choices of csn and
when we get the students in the door we
find that you know they stick and stay
that's the important thing well thanks
for opening the doors early for us
before campus even started this morning
so we're going to let you guys
take a look here at the group and all
meet up with students here the
celebration tonight is free everyone is
welcome to attend and again it's
happening here at the csn campus in
north las vegas starting at 5 p.m
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys